in your book you talk about meritocracy
and how meritocracy
is this idea that if you're rich it's
because you're good and if you're poor
it's because you're bad
and in the criminal justice system we
call this um
neo-liberalism where it's like oh if you
are a criminal it's because you're bad
and if you're not a criminal it's
because you're good
and not recognizing the complexity that
goes into it
who gets targeted as a criminal who is
not targeted as a criminal
i've been deeply moved in your work
by the recognition that there needs to
be a re-evaluation
of human value that's not based on how
much
money you have whether that be in the
economy or whether that be in the
criminal justice system
it is weird how uh we've
otherized and not expressed any empathy
for people
who are um being pushed out of the
economy and are struggling
uh you know it's one of the silver
linings of this pandemic
is that now it's clear to us that it's
no one's fault anyone who required
physical
contact you know their opportunities
have gotten demolished
and no one's looking at up saying well
they did something wrong you know like
but but there's like a strange
programming that we have in america to
kind of blame whoever
uh bad things are happening to like on
their own decisions and behaviors
if we can unlock that tendency then
we'll
actually have a chance
[Music]
all right and welcome back
to the next episode of yank speaks i'm
your co-host zach ralman
excited to be here and it's been a big
week for the yang gang for many of you
who have been
paying attention um excited to be with
you all i am wearing
my buffalo bills gear i'm wearing a
shirt that says
school of hard knocks for our tight end
dawson knox
now i realize this is not a buffalo
bills podcast um
but i hope sometimes it's a buffalo
bills fan discovery podcast
uh but if you don't have a sports team
just for your own sanity when you listen
to this
uh you become a bills fan root for a
happier episode if you will so
i'm recording this to air on monday
which means um
when you are listening to this folks
i will either be elated and do uh
probably crying tears of joy or crying
tears of
absolute sadness so because the bills
had their playoff game on saturday
and this is area monday so that's that
anyway welcome back guys it's been a big
week uh many of you been asking am i
involved
with the activities going on in andrew
yang's world and the
answer is of course i am involved are
you kidding me for those who think i
would let
our boy out in the world on his own
you've lost your mind so of course i am
guys um but we will keep this podcast uh
separate and on various topics but um as
we
as you heard last episode made a
commitment to keep this interesting and
awesome and speaking of interesting
awesome
we have a pretty we have an awesome
awesome episode i've said awesome like
three times because it is it's awesome
that's four times um
amazing episode this is actually one of
my favorite episodes
so we um this is a treat so andrew goes
on a lot of different podcasts
um and we don't put them on yang speaks
very often
so when he's doing podcasts here he's
usually interviewing someone but
um rarely when it's a good one when
andrew is the interviewee
and he's getting asked the questions we
air them on yang speaks because i think
it is helpful to balance
when andrew's asking questions when
andrew's talking about what he thinks
and you guys have heard a lot about
angels say so um
i try to only do this when it's relevant
interesting or new and this is relevant
interesting and new so this interview is
with
amanda knox and her husband chris on
their new podcast called labyrinth which
is really cool and
the concept of the podcast is about
people who have been lost um
and how they navigate that labyrinth and
for those of you who don't remember
maybe familiar with the name man anoxic
who is that amanda knox was falsely
accused
of murder while she was i believe
studying abroad
in italy um and she was tried
and proven innocent in two courts of law
but the media dragged her
through the mud um and
by just by result here she's become this
to me a just a fascinating individual
and after listening to this
and getting to know her and recording
this a really wonderful human being both
her and her husband are um
and they interview andrew and
they are yang gang they're fans and they
have their math hats on which is fun but
um
it's a really interesting it's a
different tone for andrew which i think
you guys are going to love
so they're they're talk about a bit
about his presidential run and why he
ran and talked and but the family side
and the dad's side of running for
president but then they talk about stuff
andrew doesn't always talk about they
talk about
uh what it was like for him when evelyn
was revealing her story
about how she was assaulted by a doctor
and and where that fam what he's done
or how he handled it frankly as a
husband and a father um
and his thoughts going through that
entire process um they talk about being
lost in their life
um which is the theme of their podcast
and hearing andrew's perspective on that
is is fascinating they talk about some
of the interesting unique policies that
they love that we didn't always
tout on the trail so much like time
banking um
which is a really interesting kind of
wonky i was begging andrew never to talk
about on the trail because it was too
beep
boop for the average human but um if you
dive into it it's amazing and it's
really interesting concept um and
probably a good solution for this
country
um they talk about criminal justice they
talk about humanizing the economy and
fix
and they talk about fixing politics but
a lot of it they talk about the future
they talk about andrew
thoughts on where this world is going so
it's a i'm happy i'm excited to say it's
a different yang
it's a yang we don't get very often um
and i'll leave you with this before we
dive in the episode is that
sometimes been frustrating for me as a
human um working with andrew is that
when he's
on the trail or in public um he's super
authentic do not get me wrong but you
guys see
like politician andrew you know um
happy go lucky um happy warrior andrew
and i've gotten to know
both that side but also human being
andrew and um
the the human softer side of andrew
um and anyone that works with andrew
closely
learns to love working with him or just
love where he's coming from in terms of
a mindset
and approach and honest
belief that he's trying to help that's
one of the things i love about andrews
his intentions are always
pure um so
i think this episode really brings that
out of him and that's credit to amanda
and chris on this
on this interview so this is a
fascinating one guys honestly
um for those who've been listening to
this for a long time um
i think you're gonna hear something you
haven't heard out of yang before so tune
in listen the whole thing
um and with that enjoy amanda knox
andrew yang on yankspeaks
[Music]
so i went to the post office the other
day in kobe to mail something
in order to do what i need i need a
valid form of identification and i gave
them my passport which to me is probably
the most valid form of identification in
the united states and they said that was
not valid and it was a miserable
experience
so i want to tell you about stamps.com
so you can avoid
what i had to do use stamps.com which i
now use all the time
and you get all the services of the post
office and ups right on your freaking
computer plus discounts big discounts on
mailing shipping rates so if your small
office
like sending out invoices or you've got
this like
sell things on you got to ship out
orders or you have giant warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamp.com can actually do
all of this stuff which is pretty cool
so you just simply use your computer to
print out the postage
24 7. you have to do post office hours
do at any time any letter any package
any class anywhere
it's awesome and literally almost a
million 900 000 small businesses already
use this freaking thing because they're
not stupid it makes a ton of sense so
make 2021
the year you stop going to post office
and getting the fights of the lady like
i did and use stamps.com there's no risk
and with our promo code yang you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
at stamps.com promo code yang never go
to the freaking post office
ever again
[Music]
let's start off with you know a lot of
us
know you as the ubi guy and the
presidential
you know candidate and the man who made
ubi
even an idea for a lot of people um
you're also a dad though and a husband
and how do you feel like that has
informed
your ideas about the value of human
beings that goes beyond
economic value i would never
have thought about running for president
if not from my experience as a parent
when our son christopher was born
in 2012. it was so transformative uh for
evelyn and me and we struggled mightily
in part because christopher was a very
difficult child um
whenever he woke up he would uh scream
and cry to a degree where i thought like
is that
normal like behavior and you don't know
because you're a first-time parent
uh you know years later we had another
child who did not
scream at the moment he opened his eyes
and then you thought well like
wow like there's a world where um
so so as first time parents it was very
difficult and confusing it turned out
that
christopher is autistic and realizing
that when he was approximately
four years old was actually a relief
because it kind of helped contextualize
the struggles
so seeing what evelyn and i were going
through
i just thought to myself wow we're
well there are two of us and we're
educated and have resources
and i was kind of cocky going in because
i thought a lot of people have kids like
how bad can it be
um and then you and then you have a
child and
uh and then you're like oh this is
actually really
um stretching my soul in a way that i
had not anticipated in testing my
marriage
and made me
reflect on uh
like the way i was structuring my life a
friend of mine
said it to me in a way that like that
stuck with me he said it's like the
first time in your life where just
trying harder
doesn't work uh where you know like you
uh and and i've been like a fairly
you know um ambitious
professional and since i started
businesses and i was doing things and i
was able to put myself out there and
just feel like well what's the worst
that can happen you know i fail
like and i have failed a number of times
um
and then you just get up and try and
keep pushing
um with some struggles uh but my friend
was right that
when it comes to parenting it's not like
you just wake up the next day and be
like and today where you know today
we're gonna just like roll up our
sleeves and do great work or whatever
like
it doesn't really work like that right
any parent who's listening to this knows
what i mean
um so we were struggling with it uh and
i knew some of the numbers around
uh the financial stresses and challenges
that
tens of millions of americans were
facing i knew the numbers around
a single parenthood in motherhood and
how that's the new normal in our country
and i just cannot imagine being a parent
and going through it alone um given what
evel and i were
were um facing and
we had a lot going for us uh so all of
that
helped push me to think well we're like
we need to do things better for people
and run for and there's really no
feasible way i saw to try and get some
of the
changes across the finish line that did
not involve something very very
uh big like running for president
um and what the the tough part is that
running for president took me away from
my family a whole lot
so it's like my family inspired me to
run and then
the family had to do without dad for
the better part of two years what was
that
process of that um discussion with
evelyn like
about choosing to run like how drawn out
was it and
do you remember the moment when you
finally decided
i'm for sure doing it uh
evelyn is a true partner
to an entrepreneur where when i first
started talking about it she was like i
wonder where this is going to go
you know she'd been through a version of
that before when i i started
an organization venture for america i
was a non-profit that i started in 2011
and it was just an idea and i said look
i think we should train an
uh army of hundreds even thousands of
entrepreneurs to start businesses in
detroit
and new orleans and baltimore and
cleveland and st louis
uh and she was there for that we joked
sometimes that there was like a bait and
switch because when she and i were
dating and got married i was a pretty
normal guy and i had like a
job that you could kind of put your
finger on and then
when my when my company was acquired
in 09 i started thinking look i want to
try and uh start this new organization
in 2010 2011 uh and so she'd
been through that journey with me where
she saw that okay
uh uh you don't know where the journey
is going to take you necessarily
um but it it it's something that you can
undertake together and that there are
some um real joys to it
as well as some some troughs and tough
times and so i think she took
my uh talking about running for
president
very very similarly where she was like
well i don't know where this is going to
go
we joked later that um she would only
come out on the trail after i was
pulling at three or four percent
sort of as an example because like if if
if you're a
let's say a massive public figure and
you say um
hey to your wife like i'm going to run
for president it's going to transform
our lives the press is going to like you
know scrutinize us and all this stuff
and none of that necessarily was true
when andrew yang was talking about it
in in 2017 when i say hey i would run
for president like
you know the most likely scenario is
that everyone ignores you and no one
no one's the wiser so it's not like you
have to have this like are you ready for
your
life to be scrutinized because because
there's a very real chance that uh that
that would never actually come to pass
but it did come to pass and i'm grateful
to all the people
who supported my run uh including you
amanda so thank you
i mean your run has meant a lot
to us um because and i mean maybe this
is
kind of where i can steer the
conversation towards criminal justice
um because you know i think that
the thing that really struck me about
your campaign and your ideas
is how it puts the value of a human
being
back on that human being right and i
think that one of the things that i've
found
about the criminal justice system is how
dehumanizing it can be to
everyone that ends up getting sucked
into it
and including the loved ones and support
persons of people who are directly
impacted by the criminal justice system
including yourself and i think that one
of the things that doesn't get talked
about enough
is how being touched by the criminal
justice system
as a loved one and as a support person
is really really impactful and i was
wondering if you could maybe speak
to your experience of that
certainly incredibly proud of evelyn
stepping forward and
telling her story about what happened
with her doctor
and i obviously knew before the public
revelation
but most all of my friends and family
did not know
and evelyn came forward in part because
her doctor uh had gotten
off with essentially a slap on the wrist
in early retirement where he said uh
you know he wasn't on on a serious
offender list he was at home in his
house in new
jersey and evelyn said well that's
awful and happily now
thanks in part to or really almost
entirely to evelyn coming forward
federal charges have been brought
against that doctor and and now he's
going to be incarcerated uh and
literally at this point unfortunately
hundreds of women have stepped forward
and said that the same thing happened to
them from the same doctor
over a period of years uh so
we've been fortunate that people have
listened to evelyn but
one of the things that we don't talk
enough about is that there were women
who came forward very very bravely
uh in a heartbreaking fashion about the
same doctor
prior to evelyn uh and just no one paid
attention
and one of the reasons why evelyn felt
that she had to step forward was that
she said wait a minute i actually could
shine a light on this in a way that
people would
listen and take real action
and it was just so rare because we knew
that that was just not the case for
other women and you were seeing it right
in front of us where evelyn actually
felt this uh this obligation because she
saw the bravery of these other women who
were
uh literally on the steps of city hall
saying this doctor did this to me and
then just no one was showing up to the
press conference
hmm shoot yeah i mean
how was it for you to support her
through that becoming sort of the face
of
all of these women who had been targeted
by the serial predator
it was uh a balance because
i just wanted to support her and
whatever she did uh you know i never
wanted her to feel like i
um wanted her to take a particular
course of action that she wasn't 100
um self-generating really
uh i i think i did say at one point i
was like baby i will support anything
you do
and it you know and uh like obviously
um the natural thing to do would be to
not necessarily
take yourself
and make yourself an open book to the
public in this way
but i
hate these people and these institutions
that have done this to you and have
enabled this to be
done to you and if you want to
go after them like i am completely
on board and i would love to help um
so so so there there was like there was
zero
um uh
self-consciousness on that level from me
though though it was still
uh heart-wrenching when she did
sit with dana on cnn because that
um clip was seen so many times
where she and i got hundreds of text
messages
from friends and family who would just
say like i never knew and of course like
you know how would they
uh and i think i i'd underestimated um
the emotion of that that
the day uh and and sharing something
with people who let's say saw us every
you know
day or every week or whatnot and did not
know this about our family and then all
of a sudden they do know
uh and and then they talk to you about
it because
obviously it's like well you know i see
you and i never knew this happened to
evelyn
um so i i guess i have something of a
pattern of not
appreciating what that that emotional
impact will be until
it happens um because like i i just knew
it was the right thing to do
um but uh but it wasn't my right thing
to do
you know it was like like it like it had
to be evelyn's right thing to do
and if evelyn had chosen not to step
forward that would have been the right
thing to do too
in the sense that you know like everyone
has to make their own decision
uh and you can't force anyone to to
go through something in the public eye
in that way
um and say it's obligatory i mean that's
not right uh you know like for people to
know all these intimate details of
something that happened to you and your
family
uh if you're willing to share that then
it's a real source of
inspiration and strength to me um but
it's not something you would ever
in my view uh push someone to do if they
didn't want to do it themselves
yeah yeah i think especially there's
that danger
for um this but i don't know why this is
the case but especially when women
come forward there's this sense of like
oh are you just trying to get attention
by talking about this it's like what do
you
like anyway that's just i mean your
story speaks to this too amanda and
there's such a powerful gendered element
to it too it was so bizarre like the way
you were treated
was uh insane
in my view um where it just
spoke to the fact that there was like a
a
reality that was depicted that was
completely
disconnected from the actual uh facts in
actual reality
uh and of course it would not have
happened if you were
not a woman you know like like that this
crazy media depiction of you
that and ended up um having you
incarcerated as an innocent person for
years
uh that there is
there's like an edification process i
think that happens when you're
uh married or to to someone
um or you just have women in your life
that you're very close to
where you see just how unfair and
misogynist
the world is uh towards women on
so many levels really every level and
i'm so grateful that you saw my campaign
as trying to
value humanity um in the face of these
institutions
i think one of the the great struggles
we're facing right now
and our criminal justice institutions
are top of the list
where you look up in terms of their
perpetration because
if you uh run a foul of them you lose
your life you lose your freedom like you
know
all these terrible things uh but but
what we're seeing
to me uh humanity lose to
institutions on so many fronts uh you
know where
when we decided to have the tagline for
my campaign humanity first
uh it was radical yeah but then you
reflect on it and you're like well what
the heck else could be
first yep you know it was it was so
it was so wild
yeah it was like what do you argue for
it is it's like capital first
machines first institutions first um
but we we have been so subjugated where
we literally are
putting uh capital institutions
machines ahead of our own needs uh on so
many levels
uh and that's what we have to change you
know we we have to get enough of us
together to say we are actually the most
important
uh the important things in life is just
us our families each other
and that starts with
recognizing uh the realities that women
face
on so many levels
[Music]
i was staying with my parents for
portions of the pandemic they have an
old mattress that i am sleeping on
three weeks in or so my back was on
fire and i think those who ever slept on
a bad mattress
have felt this before which is why i'm
pumped to say
i want to talk about helix sleep i have
a helix mattress
it's in my new apartment in new york
city and
it is so much better my back feels
amazing
um and what's cool about helix is they
customize it for you so you go online
and you check out their little quiz it's
like a two minute quiz and they match
you with the right mattress in size
you click you get it you get it asap it
comes in this very
tightly packaged box that you rip it
open and boop there goes the mattress
it's so
freaking easy you can get a bed frame
too it is fantastic
and it's not just me helix was awarded
number one best overall mattress in 2020
in gq and wired magazine so go to
helixsleep.com
yang and take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to your
customized mattress give me the best
sleep your life and right now they're
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows which i did get and they're
lovely
that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com for up
to 200
off and two free pillows you will not
regret this invest in a good freaking
mattress and if you do it use our
discount with helix it's freaking great
okay bye
[Music]
you're speaking about evelyn's
experience really like highlighting the
fact that the criminal justice system
tends to treat people differently
depending on
you know if they can afford counsel if
like what
you know how powerful they are within an
institution
like are they going to be targeted by a
prosecution or not targeted by
prosecution
are people going to listen to the to a
victim or
are because they're famous potentially
or because they're not
like and i think that you know it what
it ultimately comes down to and what i
love about how
your approach to solving world's
problems being humanity first is you
know
in your book you talk about meritocracy
and how meritocracy
is this idea that if you're rich it's
because you're good and if you're poor
it's because you're bad
and in the criminal justice system we
call this um
neo-liberalism where it's like oh if you
if you are a criminal it's because
you're bad and if you're
not a criminal it's because you're good
and not recognizing the complexity
that goes into it who gets targeted as a
criminal who is not targeted as a
criminal
um how we even decide what crimes how to
recognize crimes and how to punish them
um and so like i've been deeply moved
in your work by the recognition that
there needs to be a re-evaluation
of human value that's not based on
how much money you have whether that be
in the economy or whether that be in the
criminal justice system
yeah and putting that um humanity first
um
as you step into an arena like politics
which is you know seemingly designed to
turn you into a caricature
um i it's interesting how you try to cut
through that i think by displaying
um vulnerability you know like talking
about christopher's
autism even you know evelyn stepping
forward
and you alongside their um bringing your
own personal struggles
into that space i think does a lot to
show your own humanity while you
try to show the value of humanity in
general um i've heard you speak about
you know the the difficulty of stepping
into that media spotlight and like
retaining your own sense of personhood
because it so easily strips it away from
you even when you're
especially when you're being vilified
like amanda was yeah it's nice being
tabloid trash
but even when you're being celebrated
you know there's this sense of unreality
that
descends on you i think um
yeah yeah that that's been a major
adjustment of the last couple of years
and i'm grateful for the fact that
it seemed like my humanity became a
feature of my campaign
uh and it be it became that way in large
part because i
couldn't succeed any other way like i
couldn't out politician the politician
so as i shall be like i've got you know
and and the interesting thing is like
the media does not care that much about
your plans anyway you know what i mean
like like
you think you're arguing on that level
you're not you're arguing on a different
level
of whether people actually
will click on the link or will
want to read the story one of the
challenges for us was
and i realized this and trump is the
biggest illustration of this is that if
you're good for ratings then they'll
cover you
and so it's like wow how do we make me
good for ratings
like that that's you're stepping into a
broken game and saying like how can i
play this game by the broken rules in
order to
change the rules yeah right i've been
trying to imagine how you change the
incentives of the media so that
instead of it being you know fomenting
outrage
it's about you know informative
informative thought-provoking content
like is that even possible
no i'm trying to dig into a media reform
plan in this direction amanda because
if you look at our problems they're very
very big and getting bigger
and you need us to come together and try
and find real solutions
and the incentives around media
companies are to turn us against each
other to polarize us
uh the social media companies it's you
know amped up even exponentially where
uh you have different versions of
reality getting funneled into people's
feeds
and so the the question is how would you
try and address this
if you were to to have um control of
uh various levers and it's not easy
but i you know that but we have to try
and i think
one of the the areas where
there should be broad public agreement
um is the death of local journalism
where local papers used to be something
we trusted to a
high degree but now yeah i came from a
family of local papers you know my
that was my whole my whole family
background and they all went belly up
in early 2000s you know and not having a
local paper
has been demonstrated to be bad for
public trust it's bad for
government and accountability uh it's it
polarizes us because you just vote along
party lines because no one's covering
what's going on in your town you're like
i don't know what's going on so i'm just
gonna
you know like uh pull for the r the d
fewer people run for office uh cost of
public financing goes up
um so so that the the
the need to invest in local journalism
is very clear in a public level
uh philanthropists are starting to put
some money behind it but
the the one of the challenges is that
the scale of our problems
exceeds uh philanthropy by
orders of magnitude like 10 or 100 but
amanda you can imagine a
a world where there are
more media organizations that are
essentially market insensitive
where they just put out content that
they're excited about and believe in
and it doesn't really matter whether
people find it
scintillating um or the ratings are high
and there are a couple of kernels of
that that exist right now
uh so that when i was running for
president you know the
only folks that interviewed me in a lot
of places i went npr
stations like
so so we have uh national public radio
we have pbs and the public tv no one
watch that stuff obviously we have
c-span
um uh so you have these things that are
very very dull
and market insensitive
then you have podcasts which is a whole
another interesting realm and so you can
imagine a world where
like for example let's say cnn ran an
hour-long conversation
with someone that was kind of podcast
style it's called long form instead of
having the cadence of cable
news hits you can imagine a world where
um you have government uh subsidies for
that kind of programming where it's like
hey you run something boring
yeah we'll we'll make you whole by like
essentially like filling that
advertising hole so you don't need to
worry about it that time
um like there are things you could do in
that direction that i think are going to
be increasingly necessary
because there are three major problems
one local journalism is dying two media
benefits from our polarization and three
social media makes everything nastier
more negative more vitriolic
and less real and that's going to become
worse when we have ai enabled deep fakes
and the rest of it in
literally like like a month you know i
mean
so um so i'm all for freedom of
press and expression um but you can't
just enable like uh
like a cacophony of falsehoods um to
overrun us because that that's what's
happening
yeah so that that problem of
polarization um
through social media and the media in
general is i think is a deep one that
you correctly
identify um but there's also
a deeper problem um which is you know
we're both um
big fans of jonathan hates um the
righteous mind
um which i think you're familiar with uh
yeah very much so uh you know i just uh
traded messages with john the other
day he's done uh such a great service by
explaining to us what is going on
i i had everyone on my team try and read
that book i don't know if they actually
did
[Laughter]
it was huge for us to like understand
that people have different moral
palettes and that like where we have a
certain moral
urgency for like preventing harm
and people and like ensuring people's
liberty
other people have like this deep moral
urgency
for you know tradition tradition
or
how do you unite how do you unite people
across that divide which is
deeper than a social media polarization
but which is has something to do with
genetic who knows what it is some core
moral difference well in john's book he
actually says that there are genetic
traits that end up leading you towards
political um dimensions
i believe one of them was a
desire for novelty and the other was a
disgust reflex
where and those are biological uh you
know you either
really like trying new foods or you
don't and i have two kids so i can speak
to this like you know
there's a lot of nature baked into this
[Music]
when i was a kid there were certain
books that just took over my brain harry
potter
for sure but also some weird ones i
loved animorphs
those books i don't remember those i
want to talk to you guys about literati
literati kids specifically because they
can offer that to kids
all the time you can deliver those
magical moments to them that i had as
kid that you probably had as a kid and
it's really really cool so literary kids
is a subscription book club that sends
five
amazing beautiful children's books to
your door each month hand-picked by
experts so
they've got book clubs for kids ages
0-12 and each kid has
age-appropriate selections tailored to
what your child needs so you can do
mystery you can do adventure you can
stem in your history you can pick
you know and choose how you want to
reach these kids souls if you will
um and let them get lost in something
it's pretty wholesome pretty awesome
they've got gift subscriptions available
for one three six or 12 months of books
so it's a great way to keep your holiday
magic going in through
2021 which is shaping up to be a very
interesting year so
great for your own kids or nieces
grandson your friends kids whatever
i need to send plenty of gifts to my
friends that are popping out babies and
literati kids is freaking perfect so
here's the deal go to literati.com
yang for 25 off your first two orders
and you pick your kids book club today
that's literati l i t
e r i t i dot com slash yang
remember no one else has kids books
clubs like these these are unique it's
awesome we found them we love them only
at literati.com
[Music]
basically what i do now is i just study
the criminal justice system and study
um different reforms that are being
proposed is this like i've gained an
appreciation
for what it must feel like to be well
maybe not what it must feel like but the
fact that it must feel like something
to be the demographic most prone to
criminality
and that is young men
and i was really excited in your book
that you spent some time like a whole
chapter
talking about young men who are not
college educated
who are increasingly feeling alienated
from
the economy and from society and so
they're spending a lot more time
in their parents basements playing video
games and i was wondering if you could
like
speak to having empathy for
for that demographic because i feel like
that demographic is having a tough time
uh receiving empathy at the moment
no it it's funny and i i think i
conclude that chapter by saying that
that
guy is within us waiting to take over if
our lives fall apart
you know it's like like so i'm a happily
married man and a dad and you know i
i've
got a lot of responsibility but i
vividly remember
just being that teenager just spending
hours and hours playing video games
uh and i i appreciate
the young men who don't feel like
there's been a place for them because
i felt the same way for years and years
of my adulthood
certainly my adolescence you know like
growing up the
uh lone asian kid and
always feeling alienated that i found
science fiction and video games and
role-playing games to be a much more
appealing
version of reality than the day-to-day
school life and whatnot and going in and
sort of the the small or significant
humiliations of of
of uh you know junior high school or
whatnot um
and in my case at every stage there were
struggles
but uh but there were also um
opportunities because like you know i i
had things going for me where i could
like
you give me a bubble sheet i can fill it
out really good and then be like oh
what's that like
go to a good school it's like all right
like you know i can do these things
and it it did not make me any better a
person
you know it's just like i had certain uh
proficiencies
that were you know primarily just
through luck of the draw you know like
who my parents were
so so i i feel like i can relate to
these guys because i was one of these
guys and i feel like every guy is these
these guys
i you know i genuinely feel like every
guy can relate to to this
uh and and it is weird how uh
we've otherized and not
expressed any empathy for people who are
um being pushed out of the economy and
are struggling
and certainly some of the directions
that
um they've been pulled in are noxious
and terrible and
and toxic uh but i met i met a lot of
people on the trail
uh and like i i met so many folks
who were from um you know different
regions or demographics or situations
where they were struggling and they were
just hurting
you know this is a lot of pain uh
there's a real lack of humanity in the
way we we look at other people's
struggles and and the meritocracy is
kind of they're pummeling us at all
times
and you know if you you you're like at
home in the basement with your parents
like uh something wrong with you
uh you know it's one of the silver lines
of this pandemic
is that now it's clear to us that it's
no one's fault you know like you look up
and say
hey like those security guards hair
stylists
um
massage or masseuses
yoga instructors anyone who required
physical
contact you know their opportunities
have gotten demolished
and no one's looking at up saying well
they did something wrong
you know like but but there's like a
strange programming that we have in
america
to kind of blame whoever uh bad things
are happening to
like on their own decisions and
behaviors uh
and if we can unlock that tendency then
we'll
actually have a chance uh and and i do
think this pandemic is an opportunity
for us that way i mean it's terrible in
many many
like in just about every other respect
but i think it's showing the
ridiculousness of some of the
meritocratic assumptions what's
interesting is that
the ways that society considers those
young men to be wasting time
um i think they're actually and i i
identify with this a lot as a former
video game um and actually we're in the
middle of a dnd campaign right now i
mean it's epic
i'm basically legolas um just saying but
like you know
um there's a lot of goal completion
there's a lot of like finding
finding meaning and achieving goals that
happens in those worlds and
for me as a dnd player way back in the
day like that taught me
storytelling and informed my later
career as a novelist
i never would have got that if i hadn't
been building stories through
dungeons and dragons um and so i feel
like those
to write off those activities as like
loner basement
waste of time disengaging from society
is to like miss the fact that
those people often have desires to be
meaningful and
and productive that society isn't
allowing them an opportunity to
fulfill and the flip side of that i
would say is that
you also have the same thing where if
you're you know
your dad used to say well you're good
thing you're playing video games at
least you're not on the street
and like a good sort of flip side of
that coin
is you know for a long time we've seen
young men who have not had great
opportunity find
value and meaning through gangs and
violence and asserting their humanity
through this sort of destructive lens
but instead of acknowledging where their
humanity is
like where that tendency is coming from
we've just decided to
lock them away for the rest of their
life um
i i had some far out ideas uh while i
was running in this direction where i i
feel like we should have
essentially publicly subsidized or free
um
mma training in jiu jitsu for like
pretty much anyone who wants it like if
you're a knucklehead you just want to
like freaking like you know
like uh like get some aggression now
it's just like freaking like
you just freaking like get you get you a
dojo you can like roll with people
that stuff's incredibly exhausting you
end up getting self-development
uh and self-improvement habits really
really quickly
uh you know it's like imagining that
these human impulses don't exist is
ridiculous it's like like
of course like you know i was a very
angry young man and so
you know like i i like i i
uh would have benefited from some of
those activities you know
like um we should just be like be like
sure like have at it
you know what like
and chris one one thing you said about
uh role-playing games i actually put in
um in uh
my other book um i didn't dream about
being the scribe i dreamt about going
into the woods and killing something
when i talked about uh leaving a secure
career to go start a business
it was like like when i was a lawyer i
was literally a scribe
and i was like i did not spend my
childhood aspiring to be the [ __ ]
scribe like i i i
i said my daughter like uh aspire to go
go into the woods and kill the dragon so
i was like well what's the dragon in
this situation
it sure as hell not this job so like so
i thought the dragon was uh
starting a company it turns out the
dragon was too tough for me and like you
know breathe fire killed me but then i
was like all right
i'll i'll try again maybe i can't take
on the dragon i'll make a new character
and
instead of taking on the dragon i'll
take something more manageable i'll like
go kill this ogre
so can we talk about something like uh
the
the thing that i was most excited about
in
all of your work is the thing that comes
after you know sort of
when we divorce human value from
economic value
what comes afterwards and your whole
chapter
on time banking and social credit
actually reminded me believe it or not
of prison and not in a bad way
so here's here's where how it reminded
me so like
prison we know is a place where time
is valued we all know it because we've
taken away someone's time
that is the thing that we have taken
from someone they are serving time
every human being that is within a
prison knows that
that day is being taken from them
because they either did something or
they didn't do something in
in my case and
i found that one of the more deeply
hurtful things about the whole
experience was being denied the
opportunity
to have value to be productive to do
something i'm just supposed to sit there
and serve time and lose life
and one of the ways that i
surreptitiously found meaning within the
prison environment
was realizing that i was one of the only
literate persons
in the prison literally like
most of the people that i was in prison
with were either illiterate or they
didn't speak italian
so as soon as i learned how to speak
italian
i realized that the social credit that i
could earn
in that environment was ex you know
helping people write letters and read
their own letters and translate for them
when they had to go to the doctor and
explain why their tummy hurt and that
became my sort of
the sort of time credit thing that was
unofficial and
the thing that i like i had this sort of
moment of revelation when i was reading
your book where i was like
okay right now in prisons we have this
thing called
earned time for good behavior where if
you're a prisoner
who um first of all in most cases is not
considered a violent prisoner which
is a little bit hard a lot of over
classifying that there's a lot of over
classifying but also i think that we
need to be incentivizing
above all else people who have committed
violent offenses to
be on you know be proactive about
rehabilitation but
we reward prisoners for taking part in
rehabilitation programs and not getting
into trouble
but it's mostly a non-action thing it's
mostly anonymous
signing and sign up for the
rehabilitation program just sort of show
up
but what if we made it more proactive
what if you could earn
time by teaching your cellmate how to
read
what if you could earn time by being a
counselor for
non-violence and we could we could use
the prison environment
to actually have prisoners create their
own value
and see their fellow prisoners as
opportunities
to create social credit and earned time
i
feel like that would revolutionize
prison and rehabilitation if we actually
put rehabilitation in the hands of the
prisoners
and and gave them the opportunity to
create that value for themselves
and genuinely incentivize them because i
feel like
right now we draw too many lines and
make it too difficult for people to be
incentivized
to rehabilitate anyway that's my grand
scheme and i want to know if you want to
get in on it with me
i absolutely love that plan um
and it's like a reasonable summary of
where we have to go
where it's not enough to just have rules
and say hey don't
do this to your fellow prisoner it's
like what about like the 10
million things you could do that would
be positive
your brain around like what could i be
doing not what shouldn't i be doing what
could i be doing
and i think that would be and from a
data collection perspective
what a great test case for a social
credit time bank system that could
exist out in the world at large you know
that was totally divorced from
the economy anyway just an idea
well i i i love it i you know uh
they're rolling out various pilots of of
this time banking
um right now during the the pandemic but
uh the prison environment makes a lot of
sense to me because you'd have
a lot of people aware just make them
feel a million times more valuable
if they looked around and said wait a
minute like i could actually do
something for
this this my my fellow inmate
and it's going to help both of you and
there could be some
actual reward system in place in terms
of the new
definition of good behavior but even
something more basic where it's like hey
you do this enough and then like
you know whatever you get like extra
like what happens in prison what can
they
do for you that you would have been
happy about oh gosh i mean
a million things more visitation time
like more in-person visitation time
i i was limited to eight hours a month
of visitation time with my parents
and that meant you know i had an hour
twice a week
i would have loved to have spent more
time with my family
um that would be huge um
also better you know employment
opportunities getting a better wage like
anything like there are a million things
that are taken away from you in prison
that you could give back
um health care health care any kind of
health care
so i i like the idea of spending time to
get time
it's like hey you do this time um you
know you do something positive for your
fellow inmates and you get more time
with your loved ones uh
so that would be something that people
could understand though i agree
you also should have gotten health care
and wages and everything else i mean
like that's
[Laughter]
reflecting on what's going on out there
we need to get people
health care and money and other things
and then
equally importantly uh construct these
positive
opportunities for folks because the the
concerns that i had when i
wrote my book uh are
even more immediate now you know like i
think all the time about all the folks
whose livelihoods have disappeared
and what that means to them as
individuals um
like we we talk about even i do it too
so you talk about the economy
uh and like these various numbers but
like i always translate to human terms
and what that
what that's doing to families
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by liquid iv
what is liquid iv liquid iv is a
hydration
drink mix and it is an energy multiplier
that i
freaking love all right so it comes in
these packets those little pouches like
almost like crystal light the whole
thing and rip them open
throw the glass of water mix it up a
little bit pound it for those of you
who enjoy a glass or wine or six uh it's
an amazing hangover cure
i've also used it for just feeling
better because i'm a little tired i
don't want to do like a full cup of
coffee or i wanted something that feels
a little healthier and is a little
healthier the one i've been doing lately
is watermelon and it's fantastic
watermelon underrated flavor and they're
also socially responsible and they've
donated three million products in covid
for first responders and food banks and
veterans and active military members so
they don't get fatigued as well which we
love
because um humanity first so here's the
deal you can get them in bulk at costco
nationwide like all over the place which
is awesome but also you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
yang
at check cap so 25 off anything you
order when you use a promo code yang at
liquid
iv.com so start fueling your adventures
start filling your life start fueling
your
day-to-day covet activities today at
liquidive.com
promo code yang
[Music]
so this um this podcast we're making
here is called labyrinths and we're
looking at
times when people have felt particularly
lost or stuck
and you're an optimistic guy with a
vision
at least that's how we've come to know
you
you know when when does the man with a
vision feel the most lost
well i wasn't born a man with a vision
that's for sure like i was uh
i was i was lost around much of my
childhood adolescence through my 20s
too because when i left the corporate
environment
and started this business that failed
and then everyone knew i'd failed and
and i felt really bad about myself and
when you feel bad about yourself
it's hard to have a positive
relationship you know what i mean like
where you show up and
um show up for the date or whatever
you're just like like hey i don't know
what i'm doing my life i'm like really
down on myself it's like oh that's
attractive
so um
[Laughter]
so so that there was like a lot of uh
struggle i was a late bloomer
uh and i hit my stride um
when i was about 30 31 um
i found a great company
uh and opportunity and i met evelyn
um and those things happened in kind of
quick succession
uh so since then
certainly the biggest struggles i've had
have been around being a parent and
being a good partner to evelyn and and
that has been
very hard at times but
lovely but very very difficult uh and
on the campaign trail there were
definitely some really tough times
um but i was always sure that i was
doing the right thing which
uh helps you know it's like if you're
uh struggling and you're not going in
the right direction like it's much much
worse whereas in my case i was
struggling but
i i knew i was doing something important
uh that
needed to be done uh and the universe
kept trying to help me
too you know like the universe is
represented by
um phenomenal people like you who saw in
me
uh someone who wanted to improve our way
of life
um so if you ask like how like the times
i felt lost the times i needed to find a
way out
uh certainly i've had many dark nights
of the soul when i was
younger uh and i'm very grateful
that those nights aren't the norm now
um because my my family is happy and
healthy and i'm
um married to an incredible person uh
and i've got all these
folks who've um decided to support my
work which is
incredible and uh the fact that even
though my campaign ended i will say
after my campaign ended i was like i
wonder what happens now
like you know and i felt all this
urgency to be like oh i'm going to start
this organization i'm going to do all
these things and
like make people know that i'm still
fighting for the same things
uh and it's been really gratifying
that you know folks still see in me
someone who's
uh trying to keep moving things in a
better direction
yeah you know my my dark night of the
soul was um
i've had i have had a couple but like
one time i felt the most lost was
after grad school i went to grad school
for poetry
twice um yeah and then i graduated and i
was like what i'm supposed to
get a job now now i'll just do more grad
school
and so i have two mfas in poetry and
then i became an adjunct english
professor
in new york for a little while i was
teaching at hunter college
and it was a slog it was low wages
job insecurity no health care you don't
know how many classes you're going to
have until the semester starts and so
i then i discovered that there was this
thing called artist colonies and i
didn't have to
have a job and i could just float around
the country by applying for these
fellowships
and i could just leave the job market
entirely and that was like a revelation
for me
i quit my job and i moved into the wind
for about four years
and that was both incredibly liberating
but then
the burden of finding meaning and
having a structure and order to my day
into my life
fell entirely upon me and because i was
anchorless and drifting around the
country and moving to a new place every
month
where a fellowship would have me my
relationships fell apart
a lot of the stability in my life was
gone and
psychologically i crumbled a bit and i
had to sort of move back to seattle and
regain my footing
so that was both incredibly liberating
for me and
a very precarious scenario and
for me it it points out it points to
this broader problem that humanity is
going to be facing
as the automation revolution comes and
puts us all in that scenario um and so
maybe this is a good time to kind of
shift into talking about your favorite
subject
um humanity yeah i mean the tightrope
we're walking where like this is gonna
destroy us or lead us to utopia and you
know
how do we make it the the latter instead
of the former
we have to speed up as quickly as
possible chris and what you went through
i think most everyone would go through a
version of that where
initially you're like oh this would be
great and then like after a little while
it starts wearing on you in particular
ways
we all crave a degree of structure and
community and meaning and purpose and uh
you know like that those environments
are are integral
uh and more and more of us are getting
thrown to the wind
and more and more of us are struggling
uh
with versions of it and unfortunately
when we lose our struggles
um you don't really hear about it in the
same way like you hear about it in your
own life and like people in your life
where you're like oh my high school
classmate um
you know uh odd or did something like uh
tragic and terrible
but you you have a lot of quiet um
quiet losses uh and and that that's
sweeping our communities really
um and it's been endlessly frustrating
to me that
like we just don't really see that in
our media reports or
talk about it it's like always about
like who said what and this and like you
do realize our way of life is
disintegrating and
we can see and feel it around us and the
rest of it
so that that's what we have to stave off
as quickly as possible we have to invest
meaning and value in people uh i
genuinely
believe that universal basic income
would be the
biggest move we could make
that would just improve the way of life
for so many folks because so many people
um just don't feel valued at all uh and
we're and we we're just bullshitting
everyone being like oh you matter you
matter but like i'm not i'm not gonna
invest [ __ ] in you but like you know
but like i said it you know maybe i said
it to
like millions of people on like you know
my um you know my
news conference or whatever but you know
like as a society we're not investing
in ourselves and each other in this way
um i talked about it i talked about it
to a group of
folks and i said you show up to work at
a new company
new job you can tell within a day or two
whether they care about you at all
like like you know um and when
when companies do invest in you
sometimes it's annoying and misplaced
you're like oh i have to do this like
nonsense training thing like what's
going on like you know and like you kind
of roll your eyes internally
but but that that stuff still shows like
they're trying
you know even if like that the attempts
are kind of uh
misplaced uh and so like that that is
like the fundamental shift is like do we
actually demonstrate that we care about
each other uh through some kind of
um real value an investment
that people will feel in in their
day-to-day lives
if we do that then we can turn things
pretty quickly uh
it's a big if so when i ran for
president
i thought the problem was that no one
had heard of universal basic income
and i thought man if if i can get this
to the mainstream everyone's gonna be
like
what like i vote for that guy i might
get a thousand bucks a month or whatever
like that number is
like i i i knew there would be a lot of
people who'd be like that's impossible
um now as we're having this conversation
a majority of americans think we should
have universal basic income yeah
and did a lot to shift the overton
window for all of us i think you know
you know yeah i played a role uh you
know hopefully
like the you know i feel like i woke up
a sleeping giant like
you all and everyone else gave me like a
stick and i was like poke poke poke
but but the thing i've realized now is
that
uh our government does not actually
respond to what the majority of us think
uh that there are a lot of things that
we might be passionate about and you all
are doing work in this direction let's
say a majority of americans agree that
we should reform our
criminal justice system uh which i think
we do at this point
yeah yeah i think they do it's like uh
so problem solved right it's like no
actually those institutions like still
have their own
like crazy perverse incentives and
ideological
capture and yeah lobbyists all that
stuff yeah
so the the big problem now i i've
realized is that
we have to be able to translate popular
will towards policy changes
that cost people money um right now the
the major issue is that there are these
parasitic organizations let's call them
private prisons that's one example
but you have these organizations that
are making billions of dollars
and they they don't want anything to
change and so
if you go and say hey we should give
everyone money or we should reform our
criminal justice system
um that their their folks will kneecap
you um
and our members of congress don't truly
have incentives to solve our problems
because uh because their re-election
rate is 94
uh even though the approval rate we have
of them is 21 percent
uh and they they have they have like
yeah it's like in
an abusive relationship yeah we're like
at least we know this abusive husband
well there's also
even the people who would ostensibly be
allies the
you know i don't want to knock bernie
too much but like
there's this paradigm on the on the left
that the living wage is this thing and
it's just anchored in this archaic mode
of thinking
that your labor is the main thing that
contributes to your value
um and like you know i think you you
found yourself
butting up against that too on the left
right like getting ubi out there isn't
just a matter of
convincing the republicans you know
which is the harder cell
but even even those people on the left i
think is kind of a hard sell
because you have to tell them like oh
you know let's remove that old marxist
dialectic there
right you matter yeah you're not
productive
well people who are fired up and arguing
for something and then you come and say
hey maybe we should argue for this other
thing they're like
no i like the thing i like the thing i
was arguing for
and they're like all right um
so so the uh so the challenge is really
going to be to try and rework our
institutions so that they're more
responsive and more people are are going
to have to act against their own
interests and i now see a path as to how
that
has to look uh how to translate popular
will towards
action uh and it's around democracy
reform ranked choice voting
open primaries public campaign financing
like like
now i'm um i want to be like the plumber
of government or like the mechanic where
you look up and say hey
like you know another thing i'm going to
be be
trumpeting term limits like you know 75
percent of americans think that
we should have term limits for your reps
when they go to washington they should
come back at some point
uh and there was actually a movement in
the states
where they were starting to adopt term
limits for their representatives like
just unilaterally in the states they
were like hey
you know we we send you you have to come
back and then there's a supreme court
case being like actually no states you
can't determine that
like that's not a state thing
and you had dozens of states that were
doing it because 75
of americans plus
know that it's a good idea so these are
some of the things that that
if we were to to change the mechanics of
government we'd have a better shot at
things
it's fun it's fun it's like you know i'm
just like the
entrepreneur trying to solve the problem
and i'm like okay
let's divorce economic value and human
value let's eradicate poverty let's like
humanize our institutions
and then you build a movement around
that and then you butt up against
government you're like wait a minute
this government doesn't actually
like like what a response you know like
what we think it'd be like why is that
and then you look and say oh
it's because uh your incentives don't
actually require you to listen to us
so you know and so we have these
fictions where they do listen to us but
they don't really
um like that there was like an onion
headline that cracked me up it was like
the american people hire their own
lobbyist
uh to work on capitol hill right
so if we zoom out for a minute to a more
global humanity scale if humanity itself
is
kind of stuck in a labyrinth that sounds
like the current minotaur we're facing
is is political dysfunction like the or
automation
the machine that is supposed to
self-improve and respond to our desires
isn't is failing
and if we can fix that then we can
address the
the bigger minotaur of automation and
artificial intelligence
um because we could we can't even
address it right now because the even
though we
know about it and care about it like it
doesn't it doesn't make its way through
our clogged
political pipes right so say that we
somehow do fix
these the pipes issue and we get to that
future like what is that
what is humanity's path out of this
quagmire look like
um in in in even going into the far
future you know are we looking at a a
world where none of us have
normal jobs or jobs at all where
i mean do you even think as far as like
say
artificial super intelligence
ideally we'd end up having roles that
are
uh generated by our needs and wants and
values
and not what the market thinks we should
be doing
so that's that's like our best case
scenario
um and in that world you might have
ai doing certain things and then you
just say
you know what we're going to do this
ourselves because we kind of prefer it
that way even though maybe you can do it
better
like i i think there'll be some of that
going on
um let's use poetry as an example let's
say i come up with an ai that's like
really really good at poetry
you still might have some human poets
around because
because you're like you know what i
guess
you should be fine you know right
you value yeah just because it's
handmade even if it's
the exact quality as the machine made
product right
yes so the the fact that it was
generated by a human will have
value uh now can we get there i mean we
have a very very tall challenge
uh ahead of us um universal basic income
is the biggest single step that we could
take that i think would just
change everyone's outlook um because
just getting that money and feeling like
wow
i do deserve that money like you you
know i belong
like i matter like that is an enormous
step forward
and then you would see many many more
people in communities construct
uh these opportunities that reflect
their own
needs and wants and values because
they'd have some resources they'd look
around and say okay i've got this money
i've gone out and bought myself some
stuff i did that in like the first
couple months or whatnot
and then by the third month they'd look
around and be like hey if 10 of us get
together we can like do something
interesting in this direction like maybe
no it's funny you mentioned that we have
a friend who's um
been writing a series called escape pod
about
ejecting from capitalism and he's one of
his ideas
is what if you get what he thinks the
threshold is about 10 people
form a commune go live off the land grow
your own food
solar panels as much as you can if you
pool your
basic income with 10 people economies of
scale allow you to effectively
withdraw from the productive economy
and survive off you know as a little
localized cluster
does that break the ubi system or is
that you know
an example of the ubi system at its best
uh i think that would be tremendous
and one of the things i believe it will
spur is like a drive towards minimalism
you know where you just have a much
lower carbon footprint because
you're in your mini commune you know
like uh
doing some farming intending and writing
and
um whatever it is that you want to work
on that doesn't break ubi at all are you
kidding like
a lot of people are very excited about
that
what do you think i'm doing right now
it's like just chilling in the woods
would you mind like quickly addressing
the
main objections just for listeners who
might not be familiar with ubi like you
know how we can afford this and you know
isn't it gonna cause inflation like
what's your
what's your pitch how do i convince my
dad who's an accountant from the 80s
that ubi is a good idea well
your dad is going to be tough but uh on
the
[Laughter]
so for the big ones the main one is like
how do you afford it and the big thing
people have to understand is look you
get the money the money doesn't
disappear it just goes right back into
your
local economy community car repairs
daycare groceries local non-profits it
ends up just flowing back in and
creating a virtuous cycle
you're not going to see massive
inflation in large part because
you actually still have a competitive
dynamic in just about every market
if you look at what's happened with our
current prices there are only three
areas where we've seen massive inflation
unfortunately they're the ones that hurt
housing education and healthcare
and then you look at them and say why
are these things going up in price and
everything else is okay
it's because those markets aren't
functioning properly uh for a variety of
reasons
you know like schools just keep on
jacking up their prices every year and
you're like well i have no choice but to
pay
like healthcare are you kidding me like
they also just have a business
well the tenured faculty disappear and
the adjunct class rises as the
you know uber drivers of academia
basically
yeah so inflation's not driven by
purchasing power it's being
driven by uh dysfunctional
industries uh and and markets where you
just don't feel like you have a choice
uh so those are a couple of the the big
ones
um and then the other big one is like
well what will people do
and i think we've talked about that yeah
which is like well you know i think
we'll figure that part out
so inspired by the idea of people just
finding value in helping each other out
like
the example of i don't know how to set
up my propane tank
good thing this guy knows how to but
what if i was alone like that
like that is something that genuinely
would help people and also genuinely
make people feel
useful like i just i'm so thrilled about
that idea
um anyway well thank you for digging
into my work
so deeply um really huge admirer of
yours as well
and i agree with you about the fact that
this really is
about humans trying to reform
institutions um
and right now in american life
institutions are winning the money is
winning
humans are losing and that's what we
have to turn around we have to get
together and say wait a minute like if
this is not working for us
then why don't we change it like are we
not still in control
are we not the owners and shareholders
of this
uh of this country is it not still a
democracy like can we still not get
together and say if we all hate this
stuff like why don't we
like shift it um and that's you know
that that's what i'm about that's what
you're about
and just uh thrilled to to be able to
hopefully
um work together to see these changes
through yeah
i mean and i yeah i think it's like
what i've found so exciting about coming
across your work again
is realizing how the economy
and the criminal justice system are like
two
like sides of the same coin where the
humanity of the people involved has been
swallowed up
by an institutional machination and we
need to like
just recognize that and say
the human beings are not working for
this institution anymore we need the
institution to work for us
so yes really apply
[Laughter]
yeah you know it's funny with a company
like amazon you know who's
what do you remember their slogan it's
like
we will own you no i mean it's like
customer first or
something like that right it means like
um a customer
something like that right for the
enrichment i know
right well you know my
my last book was um a satirical take on
amazon
launching drone delivery in detroit um
and i went to detroit for a while to
research that book
and it just blew my mind everyone should
go to a place like detroit
there's other ones youngstown right but
like detroit's a big one
which you talk about in the war on
normal people
and you know seeing the there's some
really inspiring things happening in
those places
yeah people you know urban farming
people coming up with new
new ways to utilize um land that has
that was made for massive urban
populations that is now
um has tiny tiny populations in the
midst of abandoned buildings
um it's it's ripe for
technology to come in and do interesting
things
and what i think the problem is is you
have
you know you have bezos and companies
like amazon saying oh
what a great opportunity for drone
delivery say
um and there are there are positive
sides where they can
you know their marketing department will
say well look we're bringing these
fulfillment centers and we're
building creating all these jobs which
are eventually going to automate away
completely
but also you know we can bring food to
the middle of food deserts where there's
no grocery stores
isn't that a great thing um what's the
counter to that or
how do you you know
can something be good in the short term
but disastrous in the long term
um or how do we shape those
technological infusions into our
urban collapse in such a way that
they don't lead to further collapse
well it strikes me that an easier way to
get those people food would be to
actually build that grocery store
you know it's like i'm gonna deliver it
would be a drone
from a grocery store it's like yeah you
could probably just set up a grocery
store there
i think yeah so that's my first
impulse um but you know we're going to
be
uh we're going to be struggling with the
ramifications of
um certain tech technologies getting
implemented in different places
and i'm someone who likes innovation in
progress uh but
it's clear the pendulum has gone way too
far in a particular direction where
we're just like hoping that they don't
do anything too atrocious
it's like and if they do because yeah
yeah yeah
there's like uh um there's a real
imbalance
i mean some of these firms are countries
unto themselves is what
is how someone described it and they're
not wrong i mean
no at this point amazon's passed a
trillion dollars in market value
and so if you can imagine if you're
within that behemoth and you're looking
around trying to do something
like how seriously are you really going
to take you know
like something that's standing in your
way um
they regard anything that stands in
their way as friction uh you know like
these different firms
look up and be like how do i reduce this
friction um you know like they don't
they don't really
think too much about like other deeper
concerns
well thank you so much andrew it's been
a thrill for us
to to chat with you yeah me too really
it was so delightful sitting down
sitting down with you both and uh yeah
like really just
excited to collaborate hopefully help
more people discover
uh that we can humanize these things and
uh you know congratulations on being
married like
thank you it's just the last fun thing
before everything
stopped got married on leap day right
before the pandemic so
wow yeah it's the last fun thing for a
lot of married people and i'm kidding
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you